[Music]
to be who knows who why studied
that you write the ip
which way and marrying his staff to
bellamy who was panting rockets that
[Music
] was
I can see him nor
[Music]
league farabrutto had been ago my
vatican an establishment  on display I feel
sorry for the hygienic condition they
suck
I see a quick reason but I tone them
a bit top manager that people talk
you know he went rione onavo verini show he
paid friends because he needs help this morning
[Music] at the
opera while  we do in the heart
if peace in the whole world you are a
writer
you want to learn from the people your
children and young people I wrote them
what you said
lil and brave but cannot explain
the reality we are still mina
understood what we have to do
but  think about who it all went to instead
what happened to
it is not all life
stuck knows it I expect beautiful things it is
added if you do not seem
[Music]
useless